le foyer adoma d'elancourt va faire peau
neuve
des travaux attendus depuis longtemps
pour ce bâtiment mise en service dans
les années 70 l'établissement jugé
précaire ne répond plus aux normes de
sécurité et d'accessibilité du public
preuve de sa vétusté un incendie déclaré
en juillet au troisième étage quatre
personnes ont été blessées
vous avez uniquement
une de quoi dormir les douches communes
les wc à l'étagé commun la même chose
pour faire sa cuisine interne au moment
où vous avez des bâtiments qui sont
venus les conditions de vie sont sombres
et correcte le comportement devient est
correct aussi le bâtiment actuel sera
démoli pour laisser place à une
résidence sociale 190 logements sont
prévus au sein de ce nouvel équipement
au lieu de 280 aujourd'hui une
construction à taille humaine avec des
studios de 16 m² minimum toutes équipées
là vous aurez vraiment des petites et un
avec tout le confort nécessaire aussi
bien au niveau sanitaire toilettes que
kitchen est ce qui donnera des
conditions de vie totalement différente
un mode de fonctionnement totalement
différent et qui sera plus en adéquation
avec ce que l'on ait droit d'attendre
quand on est logés quelques bains
financé par adoma avec l'aide de l'état
le chantier devrait débuter en janvier
le nouveau bâtiment sera construit sur
la zone verte actuelle pour loger les
habitants avant de détruire l'ancien le
déménagement des résidants est prévue
pour 2018